the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so yesterday we learnt about
equations of planes and how to think of
square by three linear systems in terms
of intersections of planes and how to
think about them geometrically and that
in particular led us to see in which
cases actually we don't have a unique
solution to the system but maybe we have
no solutions or infinitely many
solutions because maybe the line of
intersection of two other planes happens
to be parallel to the other plane so
today well we'll start by looking at
equations of lines and so in a way it
seems like something that we've already
seen last time because we have seen that
we can think of a line as the
intersection of two planes and we know
what equations of planes look like so we
could describe a line by two equations
then I guess about the two planes but in
the second of a line that's not the most
convenient way to think about a line
usually though because you know when you
have these two equations how do you
solve them well you can but takes a bit
of effort so instead there's another
representation of a line so if you have
a line in space well you can imagine
maybe that you have a point on it and
that point is moving in time and the
line is the trajectory of the point as
time varies okay so think of a line as
the trajectory of a moving point
and so when we think of the trajectory
of a moving point that's called a
parametric equation
okay so we're going to learn about
parametric equations of nice
so let's say for example that we are
looking at the line for so to specify
your line in space I can do that by
giving you two points on the line or by
giving you a point and a vector parallel
to the line for example so let's say I
give you two points on the line - 1 - 2
and the other point will be let's say 1
3 negative 1 so ok it's pretty good
because we have two points in that line
now how do we find all the other points
well you know the other points in
between these guys and also on either
side let's imagine that we have a point
that's moving on the line and at time 0
it's here at Q 0 and in a unit time I'm
not telling you would be unit it you
know it could be a second could be an
hour could be a year at t equals 1 it's
going to be a q1 and it moves at
constant speed so maybe at time 1/2 it's
going to be here time - it will be over
there and in fact that point didn't
start here maybe it was you know it's
always been moving on that line at time
minus 2 it was down there so let's say Q
of T is a moving point and at T equals 0
it's at Q 0 and let's say that it moves
well we could make it move in any way we
want but probably the easiest to find so
our role is going to find formulas for
the position of this moving point in
terms of T and we'll use that to say
well any point on the line is of this
form where you have to plug in the cord
value of T depending on when it's hit by
the movie
point so perhaps it's easiest to do it
if we make it move at constant speed the
line and that speed is chosen so that at
time one it's at q1
so the question we want to answer is
what is the position at a time T so the
point Q of T well to answer that we have
an easy observe ation which is that the
vector on Q zero to Q of T is
proportional to the vector of on Q zero
to human and what's the proper finality
factor here yeah it's exactly T at time
1 Q 0 Q is exactly the same give me da
food or another picture again I have Q
zero I have Q 1 and after time T
I'm here at Q of T where this vector
from Q zero to Q of T is actually going
to be three times the vector Q 0 Q 1
when T increases it gets longer and
longer so does everybody see this now is
that okay any questions about that yes
okay so I will try to avoid using blue
thanks for that's fine so okay I will
not use blue anymore
okay well for this time let me just make
everything white for just for now this
is vector from Q zero to Q of T this is
the point Q of T is it kind of visible
now okay thanks thanks for pointing it
out I will switch to brighter colors so
okay so apart from that I claim now we
can find the position of this moving
point because well this vector of Q 0 Q
1 we can find from the colonnades of Q 0
and Q 1 so we just subtract the
coordinates of Q 0 from those of Q 1
will get that vector Q 0 Q 1 is 2 1-3
okay so if I look at it well so let's
call X of T y of T and Z of T the
coordinates of the point that's moving
on the line then we get X of T - well
actually plus 1 equals
three times - all right I'm writing the
components of vector Q 0 Q of T and here
I'm fighting T times Q 0 Q 1 Y of T
minus 2 equals T and Z of T minus 2
equals minus VT so in other terms the
more familiar way that we'll use to
write these equations let me do it that
way instead minus 1 plus 2t y of T
equals 2 plus T Z of T equals 2 minus VT
and if you prefer I can just say Q of T
is Q 0 plus T times the vector Q 0 Q 1
ok so that's our first parametric
equation of a line in this class and I
hope you see it's not extremely hard in
fact so poetic equations of lines always
look like that X Y and T are functions
of T that are of the form a constant
plus a constant times T the coefficients
of T tell us about a vector along the
line here we have a vector Q 0 Q 1 which
is 2 1 negative 3 and the constant terms
tell us about where we are at T equals 0
at T equals 0 these guys go away and get
minus 1 to 2 that's my starting point ok
so any questions about that
nope okay so let's see now what we can
do with these parametric equations
so one application is to think about the
relative position of a line and a plane
with respect to each other so let's say
that we take still the same line up
there and let's consider the plane with
equation X plus 2y plus 4z equals 7 ok
so I'm giving you this plane and the
questions that we are going to ask
ourselves well does the line intersect
the plane and where does it intersect
the plane
so let's start with first primary
question but maybe we should try to
understand we have these points you know
we have this plane and we have this
points q0 and q1 I'm going to draw them
in completely random places
well our q0 and q1 on the same side of a
plane or on different side on opposite
sides of the planes could it be that
maybe one of the points is in the plane
so I think I'm going to let you vote on
that
so is that available is it too small
okay so anyway the question says
relative to the plane x plus 2y plus 4z
equals 7 this point q0 and q1 are they
on the same side on opposite sides is
one of them on the plane we can decide
ok should be better
so I see positively few answers okay it
looks like also a lot of you have
forgotten their cards and so I see
people raising two fingers I see people
raising three fingers and they see a
polarizing four fingers I don't see
anyone answering number one so the
general idea seems to be that either
we're on opposite sides or maybe one of
them is on the plane well let's try to
see is one of them on the plane well
let's check okay so let's look at the
point sorry I have one more blackboard
to use here
so I take the point Q zero which is at
minus one to two well if I plug that
into the plane equation so X plus 2y
plus 4z will equal minus 1 plus 2 times
2 plus 4 times 2 that's well 4 plus 8 12
minus 1 11 but i think is bigger than 7
okay so Q 0 is not in the plane let's
try again with Q 1 1 a negative 1 well
if we plug that into X plus 2y plus 4z
we'll have 1 plus 2 times 3 makes 7 but
we add 4 times negative 1
we end up with way less than 7 well that
one is not in the plane either so I
don't think actually that the answer
should be number 3 so let's get rid of
answer number 3 ok let's see in the
light of this are you willing to
reconsider your previous answers and
okay so I think now everyone seems to be
interested in answering number 2 and I
would agree with that answer so let's
think about it this points are not in
the plane but they're not in the plane
in different ways one of them somehow
other fruits we get 1101 when they get
three that's less than 7 if you think
about how a plane splits space into two
half spaces on either side well one of
them is going to be the points where X
plus 2y plus 4z is less than 7 and the
other one
we'll be so that's somehow this side and
that's where q1 is and the other side is
where X plus 2y plus 4z is actually
bigger than 7 and to go from one to the
other
well x plus 2y plus 4z needs to go for
the value 7 if it you know if you're
moving along any path from q0 to q1 this
thing will change continuously from 11
to 3 at some time it has to go through 7
does that make sense so to go from q0 to
q1 we need to cross p at some place so
there are no posits eyes
okay now that doesn't quite finish
answering the question that we had which
was where the weather's will intersect
the plane but what we can do the same
thing now we know not only the points q0
and q1 we know actually any point on the
line because we have a chimeric equation
up there telling us where is the point
that's moving on the line at time T so
what about the moving point Q of T well
let's plug its coordinates into the
plane equation so we'll take X of T plus
twice Y of T plus 4 Z of T ok that's
equal to well minus 1 plus 2t plus twice
2 plus T plus 4 times 2 minus VT so if
you simplify this a bit you get 2t plus
2t minus 12t
that should be minus 8t and the constant
term is minus 1 plus 4 plus 8 is 11 and
we have to compare that with 7 ok
question is is this ever equal to 7 well
so Q of T is in the plane
exactly
when minus 8 T plus 11 equals 7 and
that's the same if you manipulate this
you will get T equals 1/2
in fact that's not very surprising if
you look at these values 11 and 3 you
see that 7 is actually right in between
its we have eight of these two numbers
so it would make sense that it's halfway
in between q0 and q1 that we will get
seven okay and then at that time Q at
time 1/2 well let's plug the values so
minus 1 plus 2 T will be 0 2 plus T will
be 2 and 1/2 or 5 halves and 2 minus 3
halves will be 1/2 okay so this is where
the line intersects the plane
so you see that's actually a pretty easy
way of finding where a line and a plane
intersect each other if we can find a
parametric equation of the line and an
equation of a plane then we basically
just plug one into the other and see at
what time the moving point hits the
plane and then we know where it is
okay other questions about this
yes sorry can you say that
ah yes so what if we don't get a
solution what happens so indeed our line
could have been parallel to the plane or
maybe even contained in the plane well
if a line is parallel to the plane then
maybe what happens is that when we plug
in you know the positions of a moving
point we actually get something that
never equals seven
because maybe we get actually a constant
say that we had gotten I don't know
thirteen all the time well when it's 13
equal to seven the answer is never okay
so that's what would tell you that the
line is actually parallel to the plane
you would not find a solution to the
equation that you get at the end yes so
if there's no solution at all to the
equation that you get it means that you
know at no time is the traveling point
going to be on the plane that means the
line really does not hit the plane ever
so it has to be parallel outside of it
on the other hand if the line is inside
the plane then that means that no matter
what time you choose you always get
seven ok that's what would happen if a
nine is in the plane you would always
get seven so maybe I should write this
down so if a line is in the plane then
you won't say when we plug X of T Y of T
Z of T into the equation always gives we
always get we always get well here in
this case seven or whatever if a value
should be for the plane if the line is
parallel to the plane
in fact we well we get see another
constant so in fact you know when you
plug these things normally you get a
quantity that's of a form something
times T plus a constant because that's
what you plug in into the equation of a
plane and so in general you have an
equation of a form something times T
plus something equals something and that
usually has a single solution and the
special case is if this coefficient of T
turns out to be 0 in the end and that's
actually going to happen exactly when
the line is either parallel or in the
plane in fact if you think this all
carefully the coefficient of T that you
get here see it's 1 times 2 plus 2 times
1 plus 4 times minus 3 it's the dot
product between the normal vector of a
plane and the vector along the line so
see this coefficient becomes 0 exactly
when the line is perpendicular to the
normal vector that means it's parallel
to the plane so everything makes sense
if you're confused with what I just said
you can ignore it ok no questions no ok
so if not let's move to move on to
marginal parametric equations so I hope
you know you've seen here that
parametric equations are a great way to
think about line in space they're also a
great way to think about actually any
curve any trajectory that can be traced
maybe by a moving point so
so not anomaly we can use parametric
equations for arbitrary motions in the
plane or in space so let's look at an
example let's take so it's a famous
curve called the cycloid and the cycloid
is something that you can actually see
sometimes at night when people are
biking if we have something that we flex
like on the wheel so let me explain
what's the definition of the sacred
so I should say I've seen a lecture
where actually professor had a volunteer
on the unicycle to demonstrate how that
works but I didn't arrange for that so
instead I will explain it to you using
more conventional means so let's say
that we have a wheel that's rolling on a
horizontal ground and as it's running of
course it's going to turn so it's going
to move forward to a new position and
now let's imagine that we have a point
that's been painted right on the
circumference of the wheel and initially
that point is here okay so as the wheel
starts rotating well of course it you
know it moves forward and it also it
turns on itself so that point starts
falling back behind the point of contact
because the wheel is rotating at the
same time as it's moving forward and so
the cycloid is the trajectory of this
moving point okay so
cycloid is obtained by considering so we
have a wheel let's say of radius a okay
so this height here is a rolling on flow
which is v x axis and let's and we have
a point P that's painted on the wheel
initially it's at the origin but of
course as time goes by it moves on the
wheel so P is a point on the rim of the
wheel and it starts at the origin so the
question is what happens in particular
can we find the position of this point X
of T Y of T as a function of time so
that's the reason why I have this
computer so I'm network it will be very
easy to visualize but so we have a wheel
oh it's not very well I hope you can
vaguely see that there's a circle that's
moving the wheel is grain here and as
you know there's a radius between
painted blue on it and that radius
rotates on the wheel as the wheel is
moving forward so now let's try to paint
actually the trajectory of a point
okay so that's what the cycler it looks
like okay so so the cycle of it well I
guess it doesn't quite look like what
I've drawn it looks like it goes a bit
higher up it will be the trajectory of
this red point and see it hits the
bottom once in a while it forms these
arches because well when the wheel has
rotated by a full term when you're
basically back at the same situation
except a bit further along the hood so
do it once more see the point now is at
the top and now it's at the bottom and
when we start again it's at the top and
then again at the bottom okay no
okay so the question that we want to
answer is what is the position X of T Y
of T of the point P okay so actually I'm
writing X of T y of T that means that I
have you know maybe I'm expressing the
position in terms of time let's see it's
time going to be a good thing to do well
certainly the position changes over time
but does it actually matter how fast the
wheel is warning no because you know I
can just play the motion in fast-forward
the wheel will be going faster but the
trajectory is still the same so in fact
time is not the most relevant thing here
what matters to us more is how far the
wheel has gone so we could use as a
parameter for example the distance by
which the wheel has moved or we can do
even better because we see that really
the most complicated thing that happens
here is variable rotation so maybe we
could actually use the angle by which
the wheel has turned to parameterize the
motion okay so there's various choices
and actually you can choose whichever
one you prefer but I think here we'll
get the simplest answer if we
parameterize things by the angle so in
fact instead of T I will be using let's
called theta
as a function of the angle theta by
which the wheel has rotated
so how are we going to do that
well because we are going to try to use
our new knowledge let's try to do it
using vectors in a smart way so let me
draw a picture of the wheel after things
have rotated by a certain amount so
maybe my point P now is here and so the
wheel has rotated by this angle here and
I want to find the position of my point
P okay so the position of this point P
that's going to be the same as knowing
the vector o P from the origin to this
moving point so I haven't really
simplified the problem yet because we
don't really know about vector o P but
maybe we know about simpler vectors
whose sum will be Oh P so let's see
let's give names to a few other points
in there for example let's say that this
will be point a a is the point where the
wheel is touching the road and B will be
the center of the wheel then it looks
like maybe I have actually a chance of
understanding vectors like maybe Oh a
doesn't look quite so scary or a B
doesn't look too bad
BP doesn't look too bad and if I sum
them together I will obtain Oh P so
let's do that
so now we've greatly simplified the
problem we had to find one vector that
we didn't know now we have to find three
vectors that we don't know but you'll
see each of them is actually fairly easy
to think about so let's see should we
start with vector or a maybe so Oh a has
two components one of them should be
very easy well the Y component is just
going to be zero okay it's directed
along the x axis what about the X
component so Oh a is the distance by
which the wheel has traveled to get to
its current position yeah I hear a lot
of people saying our theta and let me
actually say a theta because I've called
a the radius of the wheel so this
distance is a theta why is it a theta
that's because the wheel well there's an
assumption which is that the wheel is
falling on something normal like a road
and not on maybe you know ice something
like that so it's rolling without
slipping so that means that this
distance on the road is actually equal
to the distance here on the
circumference of the wheel this point P
was there and the amount by which things
have moved can be measured either here
or here these are the same distances
okay
so that makes it a theta and maybe I
should justify by saying amount by which
the wheel has world has moved it's equal
to V so the distance from o to a is
equal to the arc length on the
circumference of the circle from a to P
and you know that if you have a sector
coming to an angle theta then its length
a times theta provided that of course
you express the angle in radians that's
the reason why we always use radians in
math okay now let's think about vector a
B and vector B P
okay so a bee is pretty easy right
because it's pointing straight up and
it's length is a so it's just zero a now
the most serious one with cap for the
end
what about vector B P so vector B P we
know two things about it we know
actually its length so the magnitude of
B P is a and we know it makes an angle
an angle theta with the vertical
so that should let us find its component
let's draw a closer picture now in
vector I'm going to Center things at B
so I have a point P here I have theta
this length is a well what are the
components of B P well the X component
is going to be almost I hear people
saying things about a but I agree with a
I hear some cosines I have some signs I
think it's actually the sign yes it's a
sine theta except it's going to the left
so actually it will have a negative a
sine theta okay and the vertical
component well it will be a cosine theta
but also negative because we are going
downwards so it's negative a cosine
theta
so now we can answer the initial
question because vector o P well we'll
just add up o a a b and b p so the x
component will be a theta minus a sine
theta and a minus a cosine theta so any
questions about that
okay so again let's me answer because
this thing here is the x-coordinate as a
function of theta and that one is the
y-coordinate as a function of theta so
now just to show you that we can do a
lot of things when we have a parametric
equation
here's a small mystery so what happens
exactly near that bottom point what does
that curve look like you know the
computer tells us well it looks like it
has some sort of pointy thing but it's
not something of a display or is it
actually what happens so so what do you
think happens you have a button point
but we had that picture let me show it
once more where you know you have this
corner like things at the bottom well
actually is it indeed a corner with some
angle between the two directions does it
make an angle or is it actually a smooth
curve without any corner but we don't
see it because it's too small to be
visible on the computer screen does it
actually make a loop or does it actually
come down and then back up without going
to the left or to the right and without
making an angle so yeah I see majority
votes for answers number two or four and
well at this point we can't quite tell
so let's try to figure it out from these
formulas I mean we leave a way to answer
that for sure is to actually look at the
formulas so
question but we are trying to answer now
is what happens near the bottom point
okay
so how do we answer that well we should
probably try to find simpler formulas
for these things okay so well to
simplify maybe let's divide everything
by a let's rescale everything by a if
you want let's say that we take the unit
of length to be the radius of our wheel
so instead of measuring things in feet
or meters
we'll just measure them in wheel radius
so take the length unit to be equal to
the radius so that means we'll have
equals 1 then our formulas are slightly
simpler we get X of theta is Theta minus
sine theta and y equals 1 minus cosine
okay so if we want to understand what
these things look like maybe we should
try to take an approximation okay so
what about approximations well probably
you know that if I take the sine of a
very small angle
it's about e it's close to the actual
angle itself if theta is very small and
you know that the cosine of an angle
that's very small is close to 1 well
that's pretty good
if we use that well we'll get theta
minus theta one minus one looks like
it's not precise enough we just get zero
and zero that's not telling us much
about what happens okay so we need
actually better approximations than that
so
so hopefully you have seen in one
variable calculus something called
Taylor expansion that's okay I see that
okay so if you have not seen Taylor
expansion or if somehow it was so
climatic that you've block it out of
your memory let me just remind you that
Taylor expansion is a way to get a
better approximation than just looking
at the function edge derivative so and
here's an example of you know where it
actually comes in handy in real life so
Taylor approximation says that if T is
small then the value of a function f of
T is approximately equal to well our
first guess of course would be F of 0
that's the you know first approximation
if we want to be a bit more precise we
know that when we change by T well T
times the derivative comes in that's the
linear approximation to how the function
changes now if we want to be even more
precise then there's another term which
is T squared over 2 times the second
derivative and if you want to be even
more precise you'll have to cube over 6
times the third derivative at 0 okay and
you can continue and so on but we won't
need more so if you use this here it
tells you that sine of a small angle
theta well yeah it looks like theta but
if we want to be more precise then we
should add minus theta cubed over 6 and
cosine of theta well it's not quite 1
it's close to 1 minus theta squared over
2 okay so these are slightly better
approximations of sine and cosine for
small angles so
now if we try to figure out again what
happens to our X of theta well that will
be psi theta minus theta minus theta
cubed over six that's theta cubed over
six and y on the other hand is going to
be one minus that that's about theta
squared over two so now which one of
them is bigger when theta is small yeah
why is much larger okay if you take the
cube of a very small number it becomes
very very very small so in fact we can
look at that you know so let's say X in
absolute value is much bigger it's much
smaller than Y and in fact what we can
do is we can look at the ratio between y
and X that tells us the slope with which
we approach the origin so Y over X is
well let's take the ratio of these two
that gives us a divided by theta that
tends to infinity when theta approaches
zero so that means that the slope of our
curve near the origin is actually
infinite
and so the correct picture is really
something like this okay so the
instantaneous motion if you had to
describe what happens very very close to
the origin is that your point is
actually not moving to the left or to
the right along with a wheel it's moving
down and then up and of course I mean at
the same time it is actually moving a
little bit forward at the same time but
the dominant motion near the origin is
really that it goes down and then up so
answer number four you have a vertical
tangent okay I think I'm at the end of
time so have a nice weekend and I'll see
you on Tuesday so on Tuesday we'll have
practice exams for next week's test